c'est au coeur de l'espace rambouillet
que se trouve le centre de sont des
rapaces où chaque année près de 200
oiseaux de proies sont recueillis et
soignés
des interventions qui peuvent débuter
par l'action de chacun d'entre nous donc
nous recueillons les animaux qui ont
souvent été découvert en difficulté très
fréquemment au bord de la route
lorsqu'ils ont été percutés par les
véhicules également des jeunes oiseaux
dont les nids ont été détruits lors de
travaux même d'événements d'événements
climatiques des tempêtes et les orages
et c est le but de les retaper jusqu'à
ce que nous puissions les les remettre à
la nature dans la nature de la chouette
au blizzard en passant par le faucon
crécerelle mais également leur art et
globaux t le centre se doit d'accueillir
correctement ces rapaces et c'est avec
la collaboration du pnr de la vallée de
chevreuse que sont actuellement effectué
des opérations de rénovation
alors nos installations en général non
plus de vingt ans maintenant et c'est
vrai que la plupart des filets on était
déjà réparée à moult reprises on a comme
sous la pression de tous les petits
prédateurs naturels qui habitent ici qui
étaient là avant nous mais je leur
souhaite vraiment d'être là après nous
donc il est hors de question de leur
faire du mal mais nous devons avoir des
volières et anchois là il faut pour
protéger nos patients avec l'encadrement
scientifique de l'ue fcs union française
des centres de sauvegarde de la faune
sauvage
le centre se doit de préparer les
oiseaux pour le retour à la nature aussi
bien psychologiquement que physiquement
pour l'aptitude au vol il faut des
muscles
donc on a des voleurs de 20 à 25 mètres
de long on essaie de les faire voler le
plus possible dans pour qu'ils aient à
pêche pas en faire un herbivore il a
juste à se pencher y trouve un an j'ai
eu son problème c'est plutôt de survivre
face à un prédateur un prédateur lui
c'est tout le contraire il passe sa vie
à avoir faim et à chercher à s'alimenter
à survivre ça c'est important de nous
relâcher que les uns des animaux qui ont
ce tempérament la tempérament naturel et
sauvage normal en fait traîne au
sauvageon au centre de soin c'est vrai
qu'on voit bien que ils sont attirés par
le grand large globalement leur donne
surtout du temps parce que manifestement
ils ont manqué que la plupart des
blessures qu'on soigne son des blessures
relativement légères mais qui les aurait
empêché de trouver à manger serait mort
de faim on les remet en forme on leur
remet du muscle ils sont au top
et oui on ouvre la porte soit là où la
cage aux oiseaux et c'est sympa c'est là
qu'on se fait plaisir et si on peut être
utile à la nature temps mais être utile
à la nature en sauvegardant la faune
sauvage une mission collective effectuée
par les bénévoles du centre